possible solution to a growing problem
for parents more than half of Americans
51 percent now live in so-called Child
Care deserts areas where there are more
children than available day care
providers having limited child care
options is causing an economic hit as
well an estimated 122 billion dollars of
Revenue was lost last year due to
parents staying at home John lordson
from our Minneapolis station WCCO shows
us how one small Minnesota Town saved
its daycare center and possibly its
future
okay now I'll do this one it's like us
every morning do I get to go to daycare
today
Kelly pollen's three-year-old daughter
Peyton can you hear it and is one of the
48 preschoolers at the Little Sprouts
Learning Center in Warren Minnesota they
paint and they dance and they sing and
they keep them busy but before Payton
was even born the daycare center in town
almost shut down we really didn't know
what we would do we don't have any
family who live here what I have found
over my experience with the daycare is
that once they close they're very hard
to get back open we would have to move
we'd have to relocate entirely Lindsey
Bugler's family had the same problem the
first day she joined the Little Sprouts
board there was already talk of closing
because costs were high and there
weren't enough workers there's no help
out there and so we had to go to the
drawing board and figure out okay how
can we financially make this work what
does it take to financially keep a
daycare open unwilling to lose families
they decided to go big not just keeping
the center open but building a new one
twice the signs
last November they asked voters for an
extra half cent sales tax what towns
usually do to pay for things like fire
stations or community centers oh my gosh
it passed by 15 votes like we won a
little shocked because I had I had made
myself think that it wasn't going to
pass so that I wasn't super disappointed
at the end of the night not exactly a
landslide out of 651 votes but a win as
communities across the country struggle
to find daycare what's happening in
Warren could be a blueprint for other
cities the sales tax levy that passed is
very unique that the only city that has
actually done that at this point in time
Jessica Byers with first children's
Finance it's a non-profit that works
with Warren and other communities to
find money for child care she says both
small towns and big cities need to see
good affordable child care as the heart
and soul of their Futures the community
needs to really look at child care as an
economic driver not just a women's issue
not a parent's issue it's an employee
your issue it's a community issue
a teaching moment from a small town
reaching a much wider audience for CBS
Saturday morning John lordson Warren
Minnesota
Community issue the way schools are a
community issue well nobody likes it to
be taxed but right this is really
investing in the future of our country
right an event and also investing just
in the here and now and your Workforce
the money off the top we talked about
122 billion dollars
it's a lot it sure is